NOT AN EASY TASK.
PAUL SIMON REPORTS.
>> Reporter: IT'S THE FILM
FRANCHISE THAT MADE PAUL WALKER
A MASSIVE STAR.
"FAST AND FURIOUS," ON ITS
SEVENTH INSTALLMENT BEGAN
FILMING IN SEPTEMBER OF 2013.
>> I DON'T HAVE FRIENDS, I GOT
FAMILY.
>> Reporter: ONLY TWO MONTHS
AFTER PRODUCTION ON THE MOVIE
STARTED, TRAGEDY.
WALKER WAS KILLED IN A SPEEDING
CAR.
THE MOMENT OF IMPACT CAPTURED ON
THIS SURVEILLANCE VIDEO.
THE CAR SLAMMING INTO A LIGHT
POLE AND TREE, BURSTING INTO
FLAMES.
HIS BUSINESS PARTNER, ROGER, WHO
WAS DRIVING AT THE TIME, ALSO
DEAD AT THE SCENE.
>> THERE WAS NOTHING.
WE TRIED.
WE WENT TO THE FIRE
EXTINGUISHERS.
>> Reporter: A CORONER'S REPORT
SAID IT WAS GOING 100 MILES AN
HOUR.
NEITHER OCCUPANT HAD DRUG OR
ALCOHOL IN THEIR SYSTEMS.
THE DRIVER LOSING CONTROL FOR
UNKNOWN REASONS.
IN THE DAYS THAT FOLLOWED, IT
BECAME CLEAR HOW MUCH WALKER WAS
LOVED BY HIS FANS.
THE OLDEST OF FIVE SIBLINGS,
WALKER GREW UP WITH A STRONG
CHRISTIAN BACKGROUND AND FAITH.
APART FROM ACTING, HE WAS KNOWN
FOR HIS HUMANITARIAN WORK.
IN 2010, HE TOOK A TEAM TO HAITI
TO HELP WITH EARTHQUAKE RELIEF.
>> EVERY TIME I SAW HIM I TOLD
HIM I LOVED HIM.
HE SAID THE SAME TO ME.
>> Reporter: AS THE REALIZATION
SET IN, QUESTIONS TURNED TO THE
FRANCHISE.
HOW TO FINISH THE LATEST FILM.
THIS WAS WALKER JUST BEFORE THE
RELEASE OF THE FIRST MOVIE,
EXPLAINING WHAT MADE IT ALL
WORK.
>> YOU HEAR ABOUT EGOS, AND
PEOPLE THAT ARE DIFFICULT TO
WORK WITH.
AND BLAH, BLAH, BLAH, BLAH.
BUT EVERYONE, WE GOT ALONG
REALLY WELL.
>> Reporter: MOST OF PARKER'S
SHOTS WERE ALREADY SHOT WHEN HE
DIED.
STILL, THE SCRIPT HAD TO BE
REWRITTEN.
PRODUCERS DECIDED TO RETIRE
WALKER'S CHARACTER.
WALKER'S BROTHER USED BODY
DOUBLES TO FINISH SCENES.
AND CGI, COMPUTER GENERATED
IMAGERY, WAS USED TO SUPER
IMPOSE WALKER'S FACE ON THEIR
BODIES.
>> THE WAY THE MOVIE IS DONE IS
PAYING HOMAGE TO HIM.
IN THE END PEOPLE ARE DEFINITELY
GOING TO LOVE THE WAY HI LESS
AGGIE IS CARRIED ON.
>> HE WAS THE COOLEST CHAPS I'VE
EVER MET.
HE WASN'T A HOLLYWOOD TYPE,
WASN'T INTERESTED IN THE GLAM
AND GLITZ.
MORE ABOUT HIS FAMILY AND
HELPING OTHER PEOPLE.
>> Reporter: PAUL WALKER IS
SURVIVED BY A 16-YEAR-OLD
DAUGHTER AND NOW A LEGACY OF THE
MOST SUCCESSFUL EASTER WEEKEND
FILM OF ALL-TIME.
>> WHAT'S THE PLAN?
>> ONE